so i just moved in so i'm still sort of
figuring out my morning routine but it
always starts with a cup of tea
my name is eliana pipes and i'm from los
angeles california
i loved growing up in la and really
growing up in la is responsible for why
i came into the arts
i was an actor and now i'm sort of
launching into a professional
screenwriting career
really writing came out of frustration
with the roles that were available to me
as an actor and so from the beginning it
was really an effort to create space for
different voices
and that was part of planting the seed
of oh i think i could do that
hi everybody oh my gosh it's so
wonderful to see you
i've been keeping a journal since i was
13 and my journal is typed
journaling is so important to me and
creative self-expression is so important
to me i think
it empowers people who aren't given
space in the world to create that space
for themselves
it also for me has been really helpful
with getting over the sort of fear of
the blank page thing
because you kind of just start typing
and then eventually i realized that
really i've started writing my project
and i just click over and there i am and
it really works
and then honestly the other big moment
that brought me into the arts was doing
academy gold
the academy gold fellowship for women
along with the wave grant was really
life-changing
and the mentor that i got on kurus has
been such a gift and she actually
suggested
pivoting the project to animation
i have never worked on an animated
project before so the prospect of
learning a new medium was so daunting
and you know for all of the incredible
difficulties that came with
this past year and with kovid and with
pivoting this production
it's also really been a gift and it
forced me to push
the storytelling forward and to push
myself forward as an artist
thank you so much i went bright red
today to match the automatic ninja how
to be done
so nails is an animated short film that
follows a young woman who develops an
unexpected crush on another girl and
when she does her fingernails start
growing at this
incredible pace which is half a blessing
because long nails are such an integral
part of black and latino beauty culture
and half a curse because short nails are
a huge part of queer culture for women
i'm black white and puerto rican and so
long nails sort of always part of my
life
it's always something that i sort of
like was proud of i'm a nail person and
then as i grew up
and discovered my queerness i also
discovered this whole new set of
signifiers
around short nails in the queer
community there's a moment in the short
where our protagonist catalina is
on her phone searching for her identity
and looking for answers about where she
belongs and who she can be
my hope for this short is that if some
real-life catalina was on her phone
looking for answers about where she
belonged
that this short would come up in the
search results and that she could watch
it and
feel seen and like she belonged
i think one of the most valuable things
that creatives can do is to
find your people then those can be the
people that you come up with
rebel rosa the storyboard artist and
character designer that i'm working with
is a friend i made in high school
we had those sort of similar challenges
that we were facing and similar
things we wanted to see that we weren't
seeing elsewhere he made every
storyboard frame
and drew over my melted goblin
storyboards to
make the beautiful pieces that ended up
in the animatic
one of the things that really draws me
to directing is the way that a director
is a leader
on set and i think i'm really interested
in arts leadership and arts advocacy and
being a leader in the culture
if we move forward with any of the
promotional things we've been thinking
of moving forward with we're going to
need an updated poster
for sure i really love exploration and
trying new things and challenging myself
it's part of
what makes art so exciting to me is is
taking on something i never thought i'd
[Music]
do
you